have you heard the conspiracy about
mcdonald's about their ice cream
[Music]
okay so i've been investigating
something for a long time
probably deeper than i've gone on any
other video for a while at least
something i never thought i would be
investigating but i am i'm investigating
mcdonald's
ice cream machines who wants to go get
ice cream
can i get an ice cream cone we don't
have ice cream right now
not today not today maybe tomorrow or
something or next week i don't know
does that happen a lot like that the
machine's down yeah
yeah okay for a few years now people
have taken notice that
the ice cream machines at mcdonald's
always seem to be down the ice cream
machine part is not working
the broken ice cream machines at
mcdonald's have been the fodder for
a lot of weird internet culture one guy
even made an interactive map
that shows every single mcdonald's that
has a broken ice cream machine
at this current moment so i reverse
engineered the android app
i think it was like it was a meme but
nobody actually knew if this meme was
correct or not but they didn't know
that that was like like an actual thing
that all the franchises are struggling
with but a couple
months ago i got an email from a guy who
said that he had
a deeper story he said that there are
important questions that no one is
asking and he promised me
answers to those questions and data and
evidence to back it up he even said that
there's potentially
something nefarious going on here i was
like okay cool another conspiracy theory
about these mcdonald's ice cream makers
so i asked my producer jack to get on
the phone with this guy
and hear him out a week later jack
called me and there's actually something
going on here i've been going through
everything and
you really need to see this okay i was
still
highly skeptical that this could be
anything worth a video or an
investigation
but i decided to dive in anyway and see
this evidence for myself
i started looking at data at internal
mcdonald's emails at these mind
numbing 100 page instruction manuals for
ice cream makers
i started talking to mcdonald's
franchise owners and
managers and yes it turns out there is
something
really weird going on here something
that hasn't been
reported on before and something that
shows that
mcdonald's broken ice cream machines
actually reveal
a bigger story about how big businesses
protect one another
even if that means hurting their
customers i never thought i'd be going
down a deep investigation into ice cream
makers
but i am and i did and i want to share
with you what i learned
[Music]
mcdonald's is getting on my [ __ ]
nerves and the
machine is always down the ice cream
machine is broken
and if we try to pull the lever this
will happen
sorry the ice cream machine is broken
the broken mcdonald's ice cream machine
epidemic has been so widespread
so long that it's a meme you know what
they're gonna say you already know
the ice cream machine is broken
ice cream machine is broken
[Music]
kinda sounds like there's a story behind
that one doesn't it
[Music]
in this very moment if you look at
mcbroken around 13 of ice cream makers
in the united states
are not working that's any red dot on
this map
what a brilliant little tool rashik made
i mean this is just
so good so jack why are the ice cream
machines always broken
so once the internet started to notice
this the wall street journal and
business insider and a bunch of other
outlets
started to report on it and the
conclusion that they came to was that
these machines
aren't actually broken they're just
going through a really long
and really complicated cleaning cycle
that lasts
four hours at a time and when that
happens the employees tell you it's
broken
because it's just easier but don't take
my word for it
so when you go there and they tell you
it's broken there's a high chance it's
not
broken it's just shut up for maintenance
okay so human error and this long
cleaning cycle
that was the conclusion that like
everyone came to and everyone seemed to
be satisfied with that
i mean i would be satisfied with that
it's a pretty tight conclusion
but hold on a second wait a minute
do you guys have frosties yeah i was
just at mcdonald's and the
ice cream machine was broken and it
seems like it always is is the ice cream
machine broken here very often
no yeah that's a mcdonald's problem we
wash our machines everything
oh that's cool is it easy to do that or
is it pretty complicated no
it's actually really easy to clean it
they're just lazy
it's the longest trigger so wendy's
doesn't have this problem
and what's crazy is that they use the
same brand of machine as mcdonald's does
and yet
they don't have a make broken it's not
an internet meme for them
nor is it for other places that use the
same brand of ice cream maker like
in and out or chick-fil-a or a bunch of
others
so why is it only mcdonald's that has a
problem
with the broken ice cream maker
[Music]
if you want a real answer on this you
need to talk to the people who
suffer the most when these machines
broken which actually isn't mcdonald's
corporate
it's the people who own these individual
restaurants or franchises
these are the people who pay the price
in lost revenue
when the machine is broken so i talked
to them i talked to managers who
actually
deal with broken machines and i also
went deep in this
111 page owner's manual which is not a
read
i recommend but i will summarize what it
says
what i've found is as mind-boggling as
it is
infuriating to understand this you have
to understand how these ice cream
machines work
and why they break so i ask you to bear
with me as we learn
how an ice cream machine at mcdonald's
works and why they always break
once you understand that you will
understand who is getting
rich every time one of these things
breaks and why they have an incentive to
keep them broken
and i was like okay i'm gonna guess it's
gonna be around like
five percent and it came back to like 13
which is
insane one question that needs to be
asked is
should you be building ice cream
machines if after 17 years
you still can't get the software right
no yeah that's a mcdonald's problem
okay really quick i just want to talk
about life insurance
something we don't really want to talk
about very often but we should probably
talk about it in fact for the past year
and a half
i've been trying to get life insurance
and i haven't been getting it because
i've been like how do i even get life
insurance and what have
been is life insurance and all that the
sponsor of today's video
answers that question policy genius is a
marketplace where you can go and shop
around and
save on life insurance did you know that
the younger you
are the cheaper life insurance is most
of you are young
and therefore most of you could lock in
a really good life insurance rate
for the next 20 30 years these are just
smart things to have
to plan for the future policy genius
isn't an insurance company there's just
a marketplace there's a place where you
can go
and choose from a bunch of different
plans
and then they handle all the paperwork
which like for someone like me who hates
paperwork
that is a huge benefit i'm going through
this process right now like i'm i'm not
kidding i'm not just saying this like
for the sponsorship
i'm literally going through this process
right now because of policy genius
and i'm getting life insurance because i
think i need to be smart like a smart
adult and do this and i'm young
so my rate is going to be actually quite
affordable and one of my favorite parts
about this whole thing
is that policy genius doesn't sell my
data and information to other companies
which is actually a really rare thing
nowadays so thank you palsy genius for
that
so go to policygenius.com johnny harris
to shop the marketplace and start saving
money today
you could save 1300 or more per
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies
you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius
i love when old legacy industries get
updated
to new modern companies that are more
seamless
and smarter and that are on the internet
and that's what policy genius is so
go check it out get life insurance
that's what i'm doing right now
let's get back to mcdonald's ice cream
makers if somebody said i have a product
that 10 or 12 of the time it's not
functioning from an injured standard
standpoint what does it look like
that's not good at all being down for 10
all the time that's like
no you can't you can't do that so let's
look at the machine in question here
it's this guy the c602 it's made by a
company called
taylor this machine is made specifically
for mcdonald's
taylor is like an og partner of
mcdonald's they've been doing business
together since the very beginning of
mcdonald's they're both based like
a few miles away from each other in
illinois they are old old old business
partners going back decades but like i
said taylor makes ice cream machines for
a bunch of other fast food restaurants
like wendy and chick-fil-a and those
machines aren't broken all the time so
it's something very specific to
mcdonald's and taylor that
explains the ice cream machine issue if
you want to start a mcdonald's franchise
you sign an agreement with mcdonald's
corporate that says i'm going to open a
restaurant and i'll make sure
that everything is standardized it's a
part of this agreement that says you
have to use
this kind of french fry and you have to
use one of two different companies for
your fryer and your grill or whatever
when this new ice cream machine came out
in 2003 mcdonald's had it in their
agreement with all their franchises
which is like 16 000 in the united
states that they had to use this machine
no other machine they could not use any
other machine on the planet they had to
use
the c602 made by mcdonald's and taylor
it was in their agreement usually
franchisees can pick between
multiple different companies for the
gear in their store
not in this case you had to use the c602
so let's dive into this machine
[Music]
ice cream is dairy and dairy needs to be
kept at a certain temperature to stay
safe the machine itself has all these
pipes that have dairy going through it
all the time so what they do
once per day is they heat up the whole
machine including the ice cream mixture
to like 151 degrees fahrenheit they
leave it at that temperature for a while
while it kills off all the bacteria
and then it comes back down to a
freezing temperature
where it turns into ice cream that
process takes about four hours and this
is the thing that you hear about all the
time as the explanation
for why the machine is always down
[Music]
but here's the nuance here that really
illuminates the story
usually the employees do this overnight
while the store is closed someone in the
night shift gets the cleaning cycle
going and then they
lock up for the night the next morning
new employees who are
opening the store for the morning show
up and they look at the ice cream
machine
and on the screen they usually see one
of two things
heat cycle was successful the ice cream
machine is ready to use or
heat cycle failed they don't know
exactly why the heat cycle failed
overnight
they're looking at this interface that
looks like it's from like 1983
and all they see is something like heat
mode failure or some other obscure
code that doesn't really tell you what
happened the machine is completely
locked out
until you successfully run one of these
heat cycles you have to run the heat
cycle even if the heat cycle missed one
of these benchmarks by like one degree
it's still just gonna tell you the thing
failed doesn't tell you why or by how
much
so the employee tells their manager the
manager has no idea
why the heat cycle failed and so they
just tell their employee to like run it
again
luckily it's the morning so people
aren't getting ice cream yet but like
run the heat cycle again so
employee runs the heat cycle again and
it fails again probably for the same
reason it failed in the first place
which nobody knows at this point
ps as a c602 ice cream machine insider
the reason why it failed probably is
because the hopper is a little bit too
full of the ice cream mix and it takes a
while for it to heat up and cool down
that massive matter so
just fill it a little bit less next time
that's one of many reasons why it might
fail
anyway nobody knows this because they're
just sitting there trying to serve
customers i worked in fast food in high
school it's a chaotic
world you're just trying to make people
happy meanwhile the person's trying to
like
run the heat cycle it fails again so the
heat cycle fails again
manager is pissed you have angry people
asking for ice cream
and everyone's just saying like yeah the
ice cream machine's down sorry
we can't do anything about it so finally
the manager calls the franchise owner
the owner of the business and says
what do we do and the franchise owner
says we need to get ice cream sales
going this is not okay we're losing
money
just call the guy
just call the guy that's verbatim what
one of the franchise owners told me he
said when things are crazy
i just tell them to just call the guy
now we're getting to the heart of this
the guy in this case means one guy or
woman which is an authorized service
technician
from taylor the company who makes the
machine remember this
the ice cream machine isn't working
right now
[Music]
now i just here to fix the ice cream
okay
uh yes okay because i've never seen the
uniform that's why i'm a little bit oh
okay yeah we switched things up
oh [ __ ] so you're still tailored yes
ma'am
okay turns out that taylor is the only
company that is authorized
to repair and maintain these machines
it's in their contract
if you call anyone else but taylor first
off they wouldn't know how to use it
because it's such a
strange esoteric machine but also you
would void your contract your warranty
so you call the service technician he or
she comes to fix the machine we got our
hands on some actual invoices
that show how much these tailor repair
people
cost it's different in every market and
for every scenario
but somewhere to the tune of 144 for the
first
30 minutes and then up to hundreds of
dollars for each additional
15 minutes thereafter so the desperate
franchise owner
the one who runs the business has to
decide do i deal with angry customers
who are yelling at me because i don't
have ice cream or do i just call the guy
and get them to come repair this at any
cost it doesn't matter
so these franchise owners end up paying
thousands and thousands of dollars not
because
their employees are incompetent or
they're bad at training but because
this machine locks them out and they
have no idea why
they're looking at a screen that looks
like this and all roads point to
call the service technician i watched a
bunch of advertisements for taylor
company people who make this ice cream
machine and do all the maintenance on it
they hardly talk about their product
here their advertisements
are more about how great their repairs
team
is innovators don't build machines they
solve
problems this is an expert technician
there are 6
500 tailor technicians worldwide ready
to help you the taylor company
a few years ago taylor was in talks to
be acquired by another company called
middleby they put together a pitch deck
of all their financials to sort of say
like look at
how good our business is and on that
pitch deck they stated that
25 of their revenue comes from this
repair and parts service of their
business
yes they make ice cream machines but a
quarter of their business comes from
just
maintenance and repairs this sort of
recurring revenue revenue you can rely
on
month after month is like gold for
investors people love this because this
is like
you can project how much money you're
gonna get every month if you can rely on
a certain
channel of revenue in your business
taylor can rely
on services and repairs from mcdonald's
ice cream machines
remember up until just a couple of years
ago for years and years
mcdonald's franchises were only allowed
to use taylor machines they had no
options they couldn't be like wow this
machine sucks i'm going to go somewhere
else so they had to use the machines
regardless and they had to use this
specific machine
that breaks all of the time our parts
and service network
is what makes taylor the company of
choice for the food service industry
no matter what time of the [ __ ]
day the ice cream machine is
broke donald is making my baby cry
how we got our hands on the software for
some of these machines
to see how taylor has tried to improve
the software component you would imagine
that with a machine that
is notoriously broken all the time it
would update their software to give
more useful feedback to the user like
hey
your cleaning cycle failed last night
only by one degree and that's probably
because your hopper was too full
try to fill it a little bit less next
time alas no
since 2003 when this thing came out
there have been
quite a few software updates but instead
of improving usability of the software
the software has actually introduced
just new sets
of cryptic error codes that don't help
anyone solve
any problems i have spent hours in this
instruction manual
going through all of the error codes and
what they mean i feel like
maybe just maybe after reading this
multiple times and like being in the
weeds
i could operate one of these machines
and maybe understand
what's going on when things fail but it
is clear to me that this machine
is not set up for the user to have
success
in diagnosing and fixing the problem one
person i was talking to was like
they just opened a store and they it was
a brand new store brand new machine
and they're like yeah in the first few
months we called the guy like four or
five times
i am blown away that a product like this
with software this cryptic and horrible
can exist in 2021. the menus are
horribly complicated the error codes are
not helpful
the buttons don't have words on them
instead they're just like a bunch of
symbols like it's like press
the flavor button press the ice cream
button to get to here like to access
this menu
press these two buttons at the same time
it's like how could you ever expect
somebody especially like an entry level
employee who's been on the job for like
a few days
to understand any of this it is a
product that is set up to fail and that
has no
incentive to improve because what this
means for taylor is simply more services
and repairs for their pocket 25 of their
entire business
is based on this and then there's the
secret menu
[Applause]
[Music]
in addition to the instruction manual
that's given to users i also got a hold
of
the service manual that is given to the
taylor
service people like this is like the
insider manual that gives you the whole
picture on this machine
i do not recommend you read it in this
manual you learn about
a separate menu for the service
technicians it's called the service menu
this one is not accessible to the user
the person who owns the machine the
franchise owner it's only accessible to
the service techs who have the very
specific code for it the existence of
this service menu is found nowhere in
the user manual the thing given to the
person who owns the machine
and yet according to this manual this
menu contains quote critical operating
parameters for the machine
so wait if this machine is breaking all
the time and you have a franchise owner
who's trying to keep their customers
happy
and there's a menu where there are quote
critical operating parameters
that the owner doesn't have access to
just call the guy
just call the guy the machine is not
meant
to give the user a clear picture on why
it's breaking
a few weeks ago a taylor service
technician realized that
he was required to install this new
software update on all mcdonald's
machines he noticed
that the update had a bunch of weird new
error codes that made the machine
worse and less functional so he posted a
video about it asking for help from
other
service technicians shortly after he
posted the video
the video disappeared when asked what
happened
he responded with quote the system
defeated me he was clearly told to take
the video down somebody doesn't want
this sort of thing on the internet now
listen this isn't some conspiracy
there's all sorts of weird conspiracies
around the ice cream machines this isn't
one of those this is actually very
rational human and business behavior
when one has a monopoly over
ice cream makers and they've created a
particularly shitty product that breaks
all the time
and gives users no clear feedback as to
why it's broken
this company has no incentive to improve
in an open market the incentive to make
your product better comes from
competition and comes from
basically ramifications you'll be driven
out of business if you don't make a good
product in this case
that's not the dynamic and in fact
having a bad product is incentivized
because it means more money
in services and repairs for this
business and the reason why mcdonald's
corporate is okay with that is because
the cost isn't borne by them
it's borne by local franchise owners who
have to pay for services and repairs
taylor has the capacity to make and
improve ice cream makers they do that
all the time at wendy's and chick-fil-a
and in and out and yet the machine made
for their og exclusive partner
mcdonald's
doesn't receive the same improvement and
refinement
instead it receives a bunch of new error
codes
and terrible user experience which
always leads
to call the guy one franchise owner i
talked to said all roads lead to
call the technician like this this
product is designed to get you to call
the technician
at this moment as i'm talking to you 15
of all ice cream machines in the u.s are
down
the standard for most industrial
products is that
you have less than a one percent failure
rate for your product in fact
the real target for mass industrial
products is 99.99966
of the time your product is working that
means
3.14 errors for every 1 million
opportunities
what you're seeing here with 15
is a dismal failure and it is the
product of
no pressure or no incentive to improve
and in fact a perverse
incentive to keep it shitty the last
chapter of the story
is the one that is still developing
today and it has to do with the email i
got
a few months ago from somebody who's
deep in the middle of this
i'm gonna lay out some facts here i'm
gonna let the news play out
over the coming weeks and months to see
how this happens but here's what's going
on the guy who reached out to me
originally was
someone named jeremy he's a tech
entrepreneur he invented a product that
could basically
fix this problem of like terrible
feedback to the user of these ice cream
machines
it's this device that you plug into your
ice cream maker and it connects with
your phone and it gives you
solid reporting on all the things
happening
in your ice cream machine something that
this does not do and it identifies
like actionable things that you can do
to train your employees
to make sure that problem doesn't happen
again basically it avoids this happening
in the first place and avoid you needing
to call the guy
all the time as soon as jeremy launched
this product it was a smashing hit with
franchise owners they started selling
hundreds of these things to franchises
all across the country
people magazine reports the chain has
partnered with
kitsch a company that created technology
to help employees manage the machines
and reduce downtime franchise owners i
talked to said that instead of getting
these vague error codes
now they actually get like solid
reporting on what is happening inside
this machine
and they can like train their employees
to help avoid this now let me just
caveat for a second
jeremy and his company kitsch obviously
have a big financial stake in this story
i'm aware that he reached out to me and
gave me some of this data
and that there's a big conflict of
interest in terms of like neutral
journalism
and my informant being somebody who
stands to gain a lot of money
if this story comes to light and that's
why the story has taken me
literally months to report i've had to
go through and independently report and
verify
every single thing that jeremy has told
me hence
this so yes while there is a major stake
for
jeremy and kitsch for this story and for
exactly what i'm saying here
the fact is everything that i've said
here checks out
on my own independent reporting just let
that be known okay so kitsch
got so popular among franchise owners
that at this conference where all the
franchise owners got together
late last year to have a conference to
talk about mcdonald's things
sounds like a riveting conference the
head of this organization of franchise
owners gets up and and says
now this is no silver bullet but it's my
belief that the information it provides
increases awareness
and results in faster reaction times
when a problem does occur
now to be clear this is not a mcdonald's
approved
piece of equipment i mean he sort of
like endorsed it he was like this is a
sweet
product it's actually helping us out
soon after this endorsement
mcdonald's sends an email to all of its
franchises
that says that they've determined that
kitsch
is actually super dangerous it may cause
serious safety risks
and they recommend that the franchise
owners stop using it
saying that they will void their
warranty if they do wait what so you
have this device that is clearly
solving a major problem and instead of
being like whoa tell us more about this
let's see if we can get this like
approved and
put it into more shops they blacklist it
and they scare away a bunch of their
franchisees from using it i reached out
to mcdonald's directly to ask them point
blank
like wtf why are you blacklisting a
product that has the potential to solve
this problem that you get made fun of
all the time on the internet for they
came back to me with some
boilerplate pr language about being
committed to their customers and all
this stuff being able to buy
sweet treats and all this and then this
little nugget at the end where they say
that mcdonald's
is testing a connectivity solution
with an approved mcdonald's supplier
in other words mcdonald's is working
on a product that does exactly the same
thing oh and the company that they're
using to do this
is called powerhouse dynamics who is
wait for it
owned by the same company that owns
taylor
they're under the same parent company
taylor and powerhouse dynamics
they're keeping it in the family oh and
this device
the new one that they're testing out
doesn't give the full picture to the
user
it continues to block them out of
certain aspects of the machine
that could be useful in diagnosing why
the machine is always broken
the theme here is the same it has been
the whole time two
old companies that have been working
together for a long time
looking out for each other and keeping
control
over data so that they can save their
own necks from being disrupted by new
tech
that is like this story like that is as
old as time
and it is happening right here in a
potentially
collusionary way again is this a deep
conspiracy is there like secret backdoor
deals going on
no this is actually horribly predictable
what this is
is old companies who are afraid of being
disrupted
by smarter better products doing
whatever they can
to hold on to their share of the market
this new connectivity product that
mcdonald's mentioned to me basically
does the same thing as kitsch
but this new device doesn't actually
give the full picture it still blocks
the user out
of those things that have been behind
the technician secret menu
the things that the user manual itself
says are critical it's the same old
story
of keeping tight control over what data
and experience the user has
so that they can continue to maintain
their exclusive
relationship with services and repairs
which is 25
of their business it's honestly smart
shrewd cutthroat business behavior but
you know who it hurts
it hurts the franchisees and it hurts
all of us who want to go buy mcflurries
this is anti-competitive behavior trying
to squash new products in the name
of retaining control so there's a lot of
nuance here that i've sort of
blasted through very quickly but the
upshot
is that mcdonald's ice cream makers are
broken
more than everyone else's ice cream
makers even though they're made by the
same company
because the company that makes them has
no incentive to improve and in fact
has an incentive to keep them bad over
the years
they've done a terrible job improving
their software and they've kept
employees managers and franchisees in
the dark of what's actually going on
with their ice cream maker preventing
them from actually being able to fix it
themselves
and when finally someone comes with a
product that could actually
fix it they squash it in the name of
their own product that does
sort of a worse version of what that new
product was going to do
kitsch is suing mcdonald's for a bunch
of stuff and go read into the lawsuit if
you'd like
and certainly in coming months we will
learn the details of
exactly how this is all going down but
for now next time you're at mcdonald's
and they don't have ice cream
just know that it's not because of lazy
employees it's not because of lack of
training
it's because there's an old relationship
between
two old companies that don't want things
to change